Now let's try and get a deeper
understanding of similar triangles Consider two similar triangles Triangles
as and triangles p which have vertices as correspond
to vertices p
which OK These triangles are similar but what else do
similar triangles convey What do they tell us about
The Sides and the Angles
Well Quite a Lot I'd Say First Let's
Look at the Sides Similar
Triangles Always Have the
Correspondingly Based on the Corresponding
Side  c corresponds to side r p
correspondingly three pairs of
a to p q will equal the ratio of b to q aa will equal the
ratio of c to r p a and p
q are correspondingly
sides and c and r p r also
Correspondingly what does this
actually mean it means that each
side is scaled up and scaled down by the
same
factor here factor with which a is increased to get p k is the same as the
factor
with which p s is increased to get q a and
a  The factor with which c is increased to get
r p So remember when the triangles are similar the correspondingly
ways be in
proportion Now let's get to the angles
Similar triangles always have the same shape What does that
tell us about the angles Yes
the measures of correspondingly
a  will be true to angle p this can also be written as
measure of angle a e equal to
measure of angle p it means if we take a
protractor and measure this two angles they will be
equal similarly angle b will be true to
angle q and angle  c will be true to angle a when the
triangles are similar the
correspondingly so we can deduce all this when we are
given that two triangles are similar
So If We Were Told That All
Pairs of Correspondingly
Are Similar And Even If We Were Told That the
Correspondingly We Can Be
Sure That the Triangles Are Similar
[Music]